well three things in common Taylor and
John so they've got their the love of
the cats now you too - yeah I have to -
I like the cat pictures again possibly
because I asked Taylor what kind of
catch they were and you said they were
what well I I only have two he showed a
picture of like 17 cats yeah that's in
your future there comes Taylor crazy cat
lady but this is Olivia damn how did it
have the accident
[Applause]
[Laughter]
donkeys you could not say that is the
weirdest cat you've ever seen in your
life here's a picture of John Cleese
this card
one of my molester
my wife two pencils not climbing your
curtsies American breed in the research
not here tonight is it didn't want to
come but it didn't come because cake me
down there really allergic yeah I'm
allergic to cats oh my I'm not a great a
massive fan of cats yeah yeah I'm in
South Africa this time next week on
Safari and I like the big cats big cats
absolutely at ease where I I'd prefer to
be and probably something people don't
know about me I prefer to be on safari
watching animals with animals more than
I'd like to be on this sofa or playing
cricket no animals and me are just I
love animals
[Applause]
people I'd rather be anywhere else than
here
I was giving you compliments new right
side my other lover but you see you're
the opposite will be opposite to some
for to a cat because if you don't like a
cat a cat will come and sit at your
ankle a cat will come and sit on your
lap that's right and that's what happens
in our intelligence pheromone shoes
dog would say master master who shall I
bite mates
cats they're really unpredictable and
cuss it like women
[Applause]
go online I would look at their
Instagram pages or their tumblr or their
Twitter or whatever and and just kind of
watch them for months and months no no
we got no way learning you do your chess
match and then you taste
[Music]